era lei nessuno potevi uguagliarlo
restava la nostra amica fedele pronta a
consolarci quando qualcosa ci faceva
piangere pronta a coccolarci prima di
prendere sonno la nostra compagna di
giochi la custode dei nostri più
profondi segreti la nostra bambola
preferita
lei si muove con noi i suoi gesti sono i
nostri frutto di una fantasia così
concreta e sembra realtà e non si
finisce mai di restare bambini se ha
sempre voglia di giocare e anche questa
volta si tratta di un gioco un gioco
bellissimo in cui io sono la tua bambola
tu sei la mia io muovo le tue gambe tu
le mie braccia e insieme formiamo un
unico corpo perfetto e nato tutto così
come un semplice intreccio di energia
un'intesa così unica che nemmeno ci
siamo rese conto di come passava il
tempo di come i nostri gesti andavano
riempire la musica perfettamente senza
limiti senza paura spiegavamo il volo
insieme unite in un unico corpo ea volte
è così difficile raccontare una storia
vera
a volte è così doloroso di pensare ad un
passato che resta sempre presente
inesorabile ad ogni risveglio
a volte invece è così semplice così
spontaneo così bello a volte la musica
sembra scritta apposta per noi
gli incontri le persone capitano come
angeli sul nostro cammino
e così è tutto facile
il risveglio di una bambola malata il
rifiuto di se stessa che il funerale
della bambola il rigetto l'alienazione
la disperazione la passività poi il sole
la luce la presa di coscienza
un'esistenza diversa ma bellissima la
bambola nuova la nostra bambola nuova
[Musica]
no
[Applauso]
[Musica]
grazie a tutti un emozioni grazie silvia
vorremmo raccontarvi un po quella che è
la nostra esperienza sicuramente il modo
che preferiamo
diciamo la forma di linguaggio e quella
che avete appena visto ma niente voglio
partire da me
otto anni fa improvvisamente per me è
arrivato un grande cambiamento
questo grande cambiamento inizialmente
dopo un periodo di disorientamento per
fortuna sono riuscita a pormi dei
piccoli obiettivi quotidiani che mi
hanno un po riportato a quella che era
la mia indipendenza
quindi ho ripreso in mano la mia vita
tornando a studiare laureandomi
iniziando a lavorare iniziando a fare
sport fino che tre anni fa ho incontrato
silvia aspetta
ho incontrato silvia che diciamo da un
certo punto di vista ha avuto un passato
molto simile al mio
siamo cresciuti entrambe credendo
tantissimo e lavorando in una passione
io come ginnasta silvia come danzatrice
io ho fatto parte della squadra
nazionale di ginnastica ritmica e ho
avuto la fortuna di coronare un sogno
partecipare ai giochi olimpici di
atlanta nel 1996 quindi entrambe
conosciamo bene il sacrificio la
disciplina che comunque ci ha regalato
veramente tanto
prima di tutto tra noi è nata
un'amicizia e un rapporto incredibile
proprio quelle energie che in maniera
così naturale arrivano e non sai come
sia possibile incredibilmente io dopo la
ginnastica ho conosciuto la danza
ho lavorato in una compagnia di danza
firenze dove poi silvia una volta che io
ho lasciato è entrata in quel momento
non ci siamo mai non ci siamo incrociati
non ci siamo incontrate ma questo è
avvenuto dopo appunto tre anni fa e
questa è bellissima energia che era nata
fra di noi ci ha portato a voler
condividere quella che era la nostra
passione e quindi siamo tornate in sala
senza obiettivi ma proprio per fare
qualcosa che ci aveva sempre fatto stare
bene e così abbiamo cominciato a
lavorare senza senza porci propri
obiettivi un giorno poi è arrivato è
arrivato grimm che green
ora devo dire che quando ho conosciuto
nicoletta ho sentito subito una
grandissima stima
e come dice una grandissima energia io
ho subito ho desiderato condividere con
lei quello che era stato un po tutta la
mia vita e quindi danzare con lei e
abbiamo iniziato ad allenarci però è una
notte fece un sogno e sogna e di danzare
con lei insieme a un carrello in ferro e
la mattina dopo pensare che strano sogno
è però mesi su carta quello che avevo
sognato e ho progettato un carrello in
ferro grimm è un nostro amico e ho
pensato subito visto che io come lei mi
ero dedicata sempre all'allenamento del
mio corpo a cosa a me sarebbe mancato se
fossi stata in lei è sicuramente mi
sarebbe mancata la dinamica e mi sarebbe
mancata quella libertà di movimento che
ha la parte superiore
quando una persona in piedi quindi non
era voluto l'essere in piedi ma era
proprio questo movimento di libertà che
una persona in piedi riesce a ottenere
attraverso il busto e così decisi di
farle un regalo
sono stata molto fortunata perché sono
riuscita a convincere un fabbro diciamo
creare e rendere realtà quello che era
stato il mio sogno e
insomma nel momento successivo abbiamo
avuto molta fortuna anche perché tante
persone ci hanno aiutato poi a rendere
green perfettamente giusto per essere
utilizzato da nicoletta e da qui senza
neanche volerlo però è iniziata
un'avventura comune sì devo dire che
inizialmente pensavo fosse una follia
avevo tantissima paura paura comunque di
rimettermi in gioco in qualcosa che
conoscevo benissimo e avevo proprio
paura di non riuscire a ritrovare certe
emozioni a riprovare certe sensazioni e
comunque a mettere a nudo quello che è
appunto magari il mio limite
e devo dire che è arrivato il momento
della prima in cui gli e silvia siamo
salite sul palco con appunto con questo
nostro nuovo amico grimm e
incredibilmente è stata una sorpresa che
non avrei mai pensato addirittura devo
dire che l'emozione che oggi mi dà la
danza va veramente oltre prima di
focalizzato troppo su quello che era il
virtuosismo su quella che era la
perfezione del gesto senza dare troppa
importanza invece a quello che il gesto
ha come significato e quindi oggi posso
dire di aver scoperto veramente un altro
modo con cui condivido energia con il
pubblico e con le persone che mi stanno
accanto
da questo nostro andare oltre è nata la
nostra compagnia è stato incredibile
anche questo non so
come possa essere successo ma siamo
riuscite con questa energia positiva a
convogliare delle persone intorno a noi
persone positive persone artisti che
avevano voglia di condividere questo con
noi
devo dire che ci sono stati chiaramente
dei momenti di paura di frustrazione ma
ho sempre in quei momenti mi sono sempre
lasciata trasportare trasportare da
quello che era l'entusiasmo l'energia
positiva di chi avevo intorno quindi
spesso credo che questo non pensare e
lasciare scorrere sia veramente
importante e tutto questo ci ha portato
con la nostra compagnia che oggi si
compone di cinque musicisti e quattro
danzatori quindi musica dal vivo ancora
ma una cosa bellissima a trovare anche i
nuovi modi di danzare insieme il nostro
preferito è quello che avete visto
questa sera la bambola la bambola nasce
per raccontare un po la mia storia parla
appunto di una bambola che come accaduto
a me una mattina si sveglia e si rende
conto che c'è qualcosa che non va che le
gambe non rispondono a quello che è la
normalità e quindi dopo un primo momento
di paura di di anche frustrazione di
di volersi abbandonare si rende conto
che le gambe sono lì e dicono comunque
che ci sei
poi superare questo e così è proprio il
momento il momento in cui c'è questa
presa di coscienza che nasce la nostra
bambola nuova e quindi un nuovo modo di
vivere quella che è la bellezza della
danza e così quella che è la nostra
ultima creazione creatura è l'evoluzione
di una farfalla è una
un pezzo che utilizziamo nel quale
utilizziamo grimm che parla proprio di
come ci insegna anche la natura e quindi
di come i cambiamenti come può essere un
gruppo che si trasforma in farfalla
i cambiamenti possono se vissuti
chiaramente con coraggio se vissuti a
per rimanendo aperte a quelle che sono
le opportunità e quindi senza
focalizzarsi sul limite ma pensando a
quelle che sono le possibilità e le
potenzialità ci possono aiutare a
trovare delle nuove delle nuove
possibilità e un nuovo modo di vivere
bello questo e siamo noi io vi ringrazio
tantissimo
[Applauso]